seeds in 2023 are Magnus Carlson and Zhu
in June neither of them have won a World
Cup before yes even Magnus has yet to
make it past the semis it's that tough
of a tournament
still Carlson is the favorite in pretty
much any tournament he plays but don't
sleep on the rest of this field Hikaru
Nakamura Fabiano Carolina
they are all here to try and win their
first World Cup for its part the women's
Field boasts Five world champions in
addition to Zhu and Jun and kasteniak
that list includes tanjong Yi Maria
music and Anna ushanina will one of them
take the next step in a return to the
throne
knockout like this it is truly anyone's
game
who will come out on top who else will
qualify for the candidates what upsets
are in store
2023 feed a World Cup